here's a quick introduction to an
ongoing controversy about the
operational definition of language we'll
get down to it by asking two simple
questions where is language located and
where does language come from biology
genetics psychology neurology artificial
intelligence anthropology and so many
other fields have contributed to this
debate great minds have even hung their
hat on one particular answer to those
two questions in the abstract they have
offered two main answers
the first is linguistic nativism which
holds that the basics of language and
grammar are innate this is the nature or
the internal perspective if things are
innate they are built into every human
being at birth it follows that for
nativists the origin of language it is
rooted in the history and development of
the biological organism which contains
the language instinct they point to
apparent linguistic universals shared by
all humans as evidence for them language
is in the genes the second perspective
is linguistic empiricism empiricists
think that language is entirely learned
this is the nurture or the external
perspective if language and grammar are
learned they are features of the
organisms environment empiricists point
out that we lack evidence for language
specific adaptations in human biology
and that all known features of language
match features of other cultural
developments for them language is a
cultural artifact other options abound
for instance some cognitive
psychologists think that the brain has
essential equipment for making sense of
grammar against the strong empiricists
assertion even if this equipment
contains no linguistic information like
grammatical categories or frameworks for
pronunciation against the strong
nativist assertion
these perspectives influence the way
their proponents collect and evaluate
linguistic data linguistic data are
sounds and texts gathered in specific
languages in order to study those
languages nativists are likely to think
that since people are born with a
universal grammar we all have an
intuitive grammatical sense speakers can
judge a grammatical sentence from an
ungrammatical one for the typical
nativist you check if a sentence is
grammatical by asking a native speaker
against this empiricists charge that
actual use and not intuition determines
which sentences occur in which do not in
a given language for the average of
empiricist you check your sentence
against a corpus containing many
examples of the language you're asking
about the more frequent its appearance
the more likely the sentence the topics
in my linguistics lessons for language
learners series start from less
controversial claims first the human
body makes noises through the air and
marks on the page that other humans
recognize as language second a variety
of languages have been used in a variety
of ways and in a variety of societies
throughout human history we observe
difference or change over time in space
third concrete observations of people
using language ground abstractions made
based on that data and not the other way
around
I hope you've gained some understanding
of this meta issue it will allow you to
appreciate the tension between
variations and universals in any
discussion about human language